[Music]
in order to deliver good design you
first off you really need to understand
what's the purpose of the design who
you're designing for what you're
designing for
the act of design is really about
improving the experience of everybody
who Encounters this design
[Music]
I personally trained in Business
Administration and work as a banker for
15 years and decided to create finance
and going to landscape design
[Music]
my start point for all design comes with
one thing to make a difference to
people's life
[Music]
design is really about a solution that
caters to the needs of different
stakeholders
bishan Park was conceptualized as a
place where when it rains we collect the
water
we clean the water and use that to
engage with the public
foreign
[Music]
hopefully by the public enjoying and
using the space they are more likely to
protect that space
this change in Paradigm allows
multi-functional users without having to
cater more land
I hope to see less entrenched positions
more compromised more learning how to
adapt our Behavior to Nature because
today we're here before us and we are
living in their environment
an example is the wildlife we are
brought back to our city including the
authors and the Honduras so when they
come into conflict instead of asking to
call them maybe we should look inwards
and see how we can adapt our Behavior so
that we can coexist
architect has just an important role as
the other professions
if you believe that you can make a
difference take that step
to make a change
foreign